world history instantly that everybody
he does in their everyday life within
your table on the student at the barber
shop wherever people are telling stories
about their past and their in a way
doing oral history but I continue at
oral history in the way that I'm
teaching it is really one sort of
formalized version of that everyday
practice of oral history and so today
I'd like to ask what is the relationship
between oral history and the everyday
sense and oil industry and in a more
formal sense and how when why do people
talk about that path and one of the uses
of this talk people make history of
course for all kinds of reasons and
tonight to focus our injury and only at
pieces where people make history at
least in part to promote activism and
I'll for that private formalized most
historical production and not informal
meetings or dinner table conversation
but for the most part things that are
self-consciously as historical and even
documentary and so I'm wondering and by
looking at these cases and what can
looking at oral tree as a particular
kind of history telling within this
broader landscape of talking about the
past and to teach us about the sources
and the deployment of the power of
history to work in the world and so in
this paper of you use ethnographic
fieldwork and interviews to explore
these questions in a case study of one
particularly historically minded
intergenerational activist community and
that squalor in New York City so suave
occupied been beyond building to the
1980s and 90s
descended them for decades using a range
of tactics from barricades and booby
traps to thrown trees and petitions
there now navigating a process of
legalization as their buildings are
converted into low-income crops and
income homeowners and so this is some of
the media coverage of that process as
their squat ourselves receives the past
these now a former squatters have been
busily documenting their own history
creating museum building an archive in
numerous university library during world
history and sharing their experiences
with the new generation of activists an
ethnographic study of this complex
landscape of historical activity allows
me to study oral history practices as I
mentioned in the context of other kinds
of talk about the past and I'll use this
case to illuminate the particular power
and the particular challenges of oral
history as a way of talking about the
past so this paper will compare be very
different context in which former
squatters talk about the past with the
aim of promoting and supporting new
activist projects the first is a series
of political education mushrooms
organized by a direct action group the
second is a walking tour of squatted
buildings and the third is an oral
history project aimed towards producing
a book so envy is Alice under for
Charlie's or illustrious genre to
analyze how oral she works in the
context of other genres of history time
to transmit activist memories for Tali
who is supposed to be known as an
Italian or destroying a train and
literary analysis who's a very
influential work on analyzing oral
history narratives as most historical
literary texts has really shaped the
field or on the street and so he argues
that in history talent because opposed
to storytelling speaker is not a member
of the listeners immediate circle so
there's a process of mutual exploration
that goes on there in
oral history or other kind of historical
genre it doesn't happen when someone's
telling the story someone that they
already know the interviewer that
becomes especially active listener they
ask for people to explain the implicit
they asked directive questions again not
things that simply happened in an
everyday storytelling encounter and
storytelling M tends to tap existing
outcropping memory and we're history
tutoring tries to reconstruct things
that might not be quite so much on the
surface of our consciousness so
participant listeners in a history
channel encounter will prompt and turn
me about the time when and or add
information the end of most history
telling is texture recording and so all
three cases that will look at today are
basically history challenge honest and
but only the final slides world history
project and his really oral history is a
sense that were used to talking about it
in it results in a written text and a
preserve document the others are more
fleeting oral performances of history
time so in comparing and contrasting the
three cases what we do contribute about
joinin standing or on the street and how
it works in the world I think you know
please indulge me in one more brief
introductory detour before delving into
the cases and talk for a moment about
how this fitted and fellowship and at
least explain why I think it's important
to do an ethnography of oral stream so
in topology as many of you may know his
plea which always use like history
interviews as a research methodology and
an entomologist have published or all
biographies of their subjects throughout
the 20th century but I'm looking at how
anthropology the study rather than used
or on the stream anthropologists have
also had a long interest than in the
world traditions and the story
and with the truth when studying
industrialized society in the latter
half the trade century interest in the
practice of history as an ethnographic
object is drunk and so I'm primarily
inspired in this work by two
interrelated bodies of literature and
this is the anthropology of historical
productions and I'm going with the work
of the shale rock trio and who spoke
silence in the past and is a work of
trying to understand how history works
by examining the process of the
production of specific historical
narratives starting with the production
of sources and he also asked us to look
at Cypress histories produced outside of
the Academy so acknowledging that school
teachers PBS producers at local storable
societies all produce history in the
name of the historian zoom and
ethnography of world history is very
important way to do this trio hysterics
and perhaps most importantly that power
is constituted of the story of history
meaning the power is not at something
that's right outside of the process of
making history but that it's infused
into every step of the process and and
so I find that useful in analyzing the
case of the hooking up today I'm also
this is the last bit of introductory
talk interested in the end apology or
archives and building off of that work
so and this is sort of a trend of
reading archives ethnographically
looking at archive are heading in the
process rather than are
is just things are touching the
documents and assess primarily don't do
the work of an stroller and then first
students have moved on to an ethnography
of our final production adapter no
people pay less on the writers one of
those students who is really inspiring
me with her work looking at different
ways that history is produced in Greek
society in the in the last 20 years and
how power works in those contracts so
and I'm doing an ethnography of world
history in the context of complicated
landscape of historical production to
illuminate how history works in our
world by looking at specific sources the
world histories and the world narratives
and and how they're produced tensor
committed so on to our pieces the first
is reading of a direct action group so
the group is 0 for 0 organ for
occupation and it's a group that was
created in part by former squatters in
New York City and with the goal
initially a building infrastructure to
support the development of the squatting
movement and response to the 2,000 eat
healthy brains so and people saw that
and in the 70s 80s and 90s there was a
housing crisis in New York City a lot of
abandonment and a squatting movement
seemed to kind of arise almost
organically in response to that moment
and in 2008 when there was also this
crisis of foreclosure and abandonment
that didn't seem to be happening and so
this group forum to try to build the
infrastructure
it was already there in the 70s and 80s
as they saw it to make that happen again
today they have to spread themselves as
a group of hearsay activists from
diverse backgrounds that have come
together to fight through human rights
holiday three direct opportunity so that
includes and squatting in there actively
engaged in spotting buildings and teens
is worked on right now and also things
like shutting down foreclosure auctions
and but civil disobedience and singing
so the meeting that i'm going to talk
about is part of a series of historic of
put of education meetings that they held
over this past summer it happened on a
very very hot july evening at the fight
over these new york city's fourth key
ways at that point at the Catholic
Worker on the Lower East Side so there
is Brenda Stokely who is the speaker for
the evening in the center of a long
conference table and sort of concentric
circles of people of coming out from
that table and really filling a tire
room as cool as hands stirring around
the edges of this massive hot bodies and
air but a very very intense atmosphere
people listen carefully for a long time
in her stories so as it other Oh for our
meetings I detected to move a strikingly
diverse and there were me babies and
grandmas people call it white people at
the hip and the earnest the organizer to
the organized religious folks and
erica's and more than any other
I've ever been in a group of people that
look like you just took you know three
random subway cars full of people and
has been meeting together and and so
Brenda Stokely the speaker came from the
1980s anti-eviction and homesteading
campaigns in Harlan and this is one of
the documents that she brought along
with her to share that history and she's
turned off by asking the group questions
rather than asking her questions so she
asked who in this room is actively
engaged in trouble for housing and and
who is personally engaged in the
struggle for their own home and so she
asked one person whose personal
engagements trouble for their own home
to tell their story which is very
emotional and she started to cry there
were sort of calls from the people the
rule of support and encouragement to her
and telling that story and does she she
started this off by building a
connection with the audience facilitate
telling her own story and to make that
connection between the past in the
present her welcome to the new
generation was that organizing only
works when it builds on the local
leadership and people going to be to be
politicized they don't need to be
convinced that their experience is
political and they don't need to have
leadership the role organizer is just to
find out what the organic pre-existing
leadership is in the community and
support them during the political work
that they already know and imagine and
the audience talk back to this point and
they did not simply accept those lessons
in the past many of the active many of
the activists in the room
you've had experiences in which it seems
like people did not think their
experiences as floatable in the 2,000
years before Christmas many people
experiencing foreclosure seem to feel
like as their own personal problem of
not something systemic and something
that they should be ashamed of rather
than up in arms about and so she
repeated her lesson in the face of this
sort of seemingly conflicting evidence
that people felt like people whose homes
were getting foreclosed didn't see their
experiences as political because when
they didn't understand those communities
deeply enough and and so this increases
the question of how knowledge Jared in
one context in Harlem in the 1980s
translates into another dominica queens
in 2008 and the storyteller your bread
Sophie and trying to draw parallels
between her time in there and but they
Taylor's that and so and this is a mode
of history telling it which there's an
active dialogue between people who are
engaged in what seemed to be similar
prophecies in the past in the present
the second case is the Museum of her
going to be playing everything urban
space and Morris as they're called
another group it was started by former
squatters and community gardeners and if
they're making some more chairs out love
em so its side effects or squatters and
community gardeners and grew from the
insight and mainly from a group of
cycling activists that after decades of
direct action and a lot of it through
critical mass bike rides the landscape
recycling had completely changed in New
York City there were
miles of new bike has more for people
riding bikes about to the new city
sponsored by sharing program but when
these big changes happened over the past
five or so years it seems them to most
people like the government had just
handed over these bike lanes and they
had just decided Oh people need bike
lanes and built them and the history of
direct action and struggle that
activists see is leading up to these
changes was erased and so they decided
that access need to produce their own
history and they need to do it in
powerful ways cruisin like archives and
museums not just by telling each other
people that they need not just by
talking about it in meetings but by
using these kinds of powerful
institutional structures to spread it
around and and so this museum is a
materialization of that idea the
physical space would suggest a corner of
a wall was under construction and is in
a legalizing squat on Avenue C and C
squat and so this is that making a
science for it out of mosaic and the
physical space is mainly home base for
the toys it's smaller than photographs
and exhibits and that the real activity
of the museum is taking people out into
the neighborhood and talking about the
history as the tours are being led and
the spaces of squats are starting to be
hidden in plain sight so where's the
past a squatted milk building way to
look quite different from other going on
the block and after the renovation cost
us visionaries to blend in a little bit
more and so this is serenity on Main
Street after you're an almost complete
renovation and you can see there's some
little and little bits of
the usual white sheet here some handmade
railing here but basically looks like a
pretty normal apartment building and
this is really how sauce on a VC and
where you can see some bits of an old
storefront Bureau left behind of the two
stores that are there in the store
months now are pretty normal everyday
shops and lower east side and so the
tour and functions first to take people
to the sidewalk in front of these spaces
and show them for what they are paying
that history physical in a way that
might not otherwise be and so you then
enter the building this is matt master
who lived in umbrella house about to
take the tour guide in and you can see
they've got Erica oh they're preserved
under a little bit of lots of placer her
laughs there at the front and and this
is the mgh a bullet space which is on
the third street and you can see there's
some lowly mosaics there police
barricade
the door frame which is a typical
spotter architecture and and so not only
to use any outlet these buildings but as
you can see as you start to enter into
the inside and you go actually into
squatters apartments where they talk
about their experiences and so this is a
pastrami having a group of people into
his face this is rolando Fellini talking
about his past in the department you can
see there's a lot of a lot of the tour
goers are taking pictures taking video
and producing their own documentation
while they're part of the store and so
when you go into a home with one of
these tours you might be asked to take
off your shoes we're going shift so it's
not to disturb the resident cats you
might get a tour of the space and a
narrative of the construction and this
is bill one of the organizers of the
museum showing off his space eh
apartment and his amazing kitchen
cabinetry that just got ins all dis
appliances or you might need told
rousing story about a fight to defend
the building some residents are
experienced speakers for amateur
historians and this is nine quickly
talking about an archaeological dig that
rebuilding did in their backyard and
others are unsure about to staying and
seemed to need a lot of coaxing from the
tour guides and so the tour guide really
functions and in a way as an editor of
reflective volume of oral histories in
these I need to play a little clip of
frank worrell
the early tour minutes and talking about
why maybe is important to give these
tours today we're going to visit three
or four swap buildings and you're
fortunate because you're going to be
able to go inside need some of the
people who live there look at the spaces
and so forth to them that is something
that just really begun to do part of the
reason being is that well I guess
probably speaking to humanize the
situation of people who are not what to
make it for real for people as you know
flying maybe are unaware of this body
but it's often demonize depressed and so
forth so the message here is really from
activists to a general audience and the
messages look what we did it you can do
it too and because we're normal people
not just not just like you we're we're
human is through your experience of
seeing us talk and entering into our
apartment and I'd like to play a little
clip that illustrates bad news Frank
inside of spaces under construction and
and what other thing to note is that he
talks about he talked to the corridors
as you and bringing them into the
project of squatting by the way to
speaking collectively for the question
of where you at funds do this well you
know none of you took building tomorrow
you just like
they have right you better lumberyard
and ask for the advanced materials and
so he brings the audience into the
community of squads if ten of you
typically what would you do creating a
space in which people can imagine
themselves as activists so as I said the
tour is really experienced almost as a
chorus of orchestrated voices frame by
the tour organizers and it also can be
seen as being like an edited volume
where the tour guides are the editors
and it reminds me of public interviews
in which people give their history not
just to an interviewer between audiences
engaged sort of like what was happening
with friends totally and so they display
an example of how the tour guides do
this work of curating contextualizing
for tor khobor so this is a jerry
peddler resident at sea squad is a very
enthusiastic historians own and talking
about his experiences and yogurt just
him sort of canned off the end of story
a little bit of Mike noise and then
you'll hear Matt jumping in to give it
some contracts to match the tour guy
here so the earlier part 84
games and Luigi we fought throughout his
breaking floor and so Jerry's telling
his stories and matt is doing the work
of bringing them together into a
coherent whole Jerry starting some of
the earliest buildings this neighborhood
it was this time in the context of the
Reagan era and and so while this can
appear to be sort of people speaking in
time their own stories it actually
created and managed and really
complicated ways by the tour guides and
more organizers so people are presented
here both as living history and as
people who have ongoing lives their
stories are extraordinary their
apartments are fascinating but also you
can be just like them and so the idea is
to inspire new activists and unclear and
at this point I think if it works and
initial evaluations of the tours he was
sure that people are intriguing they're
inspired and but there's no evidence
that they're actually inspired to act
and I think that's partially because
that's an extremely lofty goal right
most people you know takes a huge amount
to get people to become engaged in
activist project and but i think that
setting that as a goal is something
that's worthy and zooming then and this
museum takes pretty seriously so the
third case that i want to talk about is
more of the oral history case and and so
it centers around
a woman named fly and here she is with
her archives and she's a long time
squatter artist musician and writer and
who has massive personal archives and
that are highly organized and work with
her on doing this although she had to be
organized already and we're now seeking
an institutional phone acting through
booklet which is an artist book
collective is the service artist of
helping them sell or donate their
archives to institutions and so this is
her working with one of the people at
what went to get the archive into shape
for that process here's another piece of
her archive so she's created the
squatter Museum actually previous to the
Morris wheezing that I've talked about
in several iterations and in this work
that this protocol work as an artist
she's really playing with the tropes oh
and apology and of studying and being
studied of explaining and being
misunderstood so they can play a clip
for you of her talking about such things
about this process and then this is a
photograph from a museum exhibit that
art gallery I guess
call it or that was in Bullitt space at
the time of their legalization from a
show called the perfect crime
celebrating 25 years of illegality and
getting away with it be coming home
morning so this is a piece of plywood
with trowels for with roofing tar on it
that they hung on the wall apart here's
why I was really interested in
presenting it as kind of an
anthropological study and sign a little
tags for all the objects I'm like
describing them in this way described
like ancient artifacts and these people
would you know it for my crusty shores I
was like a paddle card that describe how
these people with with so their patches
on with dental floss because what
happens with the doesn't floss is that
there's wax on it and when you sew
opening where the clothes that are warm
because you know you've got a body and
so kind uses the patches to your to your
to your fabric in a very Kressley
crusting way that you know crustacea
suede you know makes it more permanent
and you'll be warmer somehow did all
that wax it's kind of like kinda like it
was kind of like studying some ancient
people yeah because you know a lot of
ways that we were living
we're kind of like ancient you know we
had word birds stones we had like you
know crazy like like crazy like setups
were plumbing and lack thereof plumbing
you know peanut buckets and having you
know the squatter sting set up so for
those who might not know her isolation
of why so patches on with Don applause
is completely fictitious it's a it's a
purposeful misunderstanding of squatter
practices and so she's playing with that
in the museum exhibit in a way that I
think is really clever and interesting
one of her other documentary projects
that i want to draw attention to before
we talk about her or on the street and
is that called peeps and here's an
example of one of them and then here's
her in the process of doing one this is
with Stanley Cohen who's the most
prominent lawyer for the squatters and
she enacted in this interview together
you can see she's videotaping it twice I
achieving it and it's an intensive
process of documentation in which she
records in orland stream with someone
and draw them while they're talking and
then afterwards they dictate words to
her that sort of summarize or tell apart
of their story and she writes them in
the background of the drawing and while
they're talking to her and so the
interesting hybrid genre between you the
morality and writing because you have to
talk as if you're dictating and when you
talk that in a way that's a little bit
more like writing but if you were just
talking normally and so people talk very
differently in the world history
interviews than they do in the peeps
sessions so this is a really large and
long term project she's engaging there's
a
probably several the new Derby's done
and is a published book and mostly it's
a collection of Dean's the public
exhibition that she does and so the
peeps I just the people that she needs
in her everyday life and traveling
around a lot of them are squatters
aren't and Stanley Harris's and Ally
just waters so why does fly do all this
documentary work at let's let her
explain it yeah well the amino whole
concept for for a squatter museum and
slaughter history I kind of like had
that idea even like way back to date so
that was always documenting and I always
like I'm kind of naturally a you know a
documentarian I always have been
probably because I moved around so much
when I was cross at me on so I always
wanted evidence of my existence looks
like I've you a new place if you like am
I really here and and also like just
just the idea of legitimacy you know
this is a legitimate flight that I'm
meeting you know I want I want to prove
it and so the next phase of this process
of legitimization and is a book called
unrealistic that she's working on and
it's something that she started with
this being and developed and created by
a collective and I'm part of that
collective the factors call it you relic
which stands for the unreal estate
living Improvement Committee but really
the
is that if you're in this collective you
yourself are a relic just by being in
the strains of life for you talking
about your history and so the book is
going to include oral histories and but
also essays art and artifacts and the
section everyone's most excited about is
called unsubstantiated wingnut gossip
and our people will be able to give
unattributed stories about their friends
and neighbors and histories and in
sections that's going to be a really
amazing thing for all I think and so the
interviews are audio and video recorded
and the transcribe and they take the
form of abbreviating life histories and
starting off how did you get to lower
east side and rather than you know where
and when were you born and tell me a
little bit about your childhood but they
do share the gist in biography and and
so sighs do it using the tropes of
positivist history in putting this book
together and she wants to know in the
interviews who when where and this
timeline that sort of the central
product of the process right now and
there's a pervasive interest in who
opened all the buildings and that sort
of trickles down into contemporary
concepts overuse and property and
assuming that she was very interested in
documented history too and I think that
this is in part because one major goal
of the project is the dedication and so
she wants to make a history that feels
like a history doesn't just feel like
people sort of chatting and casually
telling stories and and in these
interviews and fly knows most of the
stories that she's recording so poor
tommy said that in history telling the
speakers usually not a number of
illustrators immediate circle but in
this case and this is generally not the
case often their friends and the
interviews alternate between
sounding like history telling and really
sounding like storytelling and there's
China's when fly is really my memory
trying to get back and other times and
when their storytelling sort of
exploiting me outcropping of memory as
he said so I want to play a little clip
it illustrates this and this is an old
picture from this mind that they are
talking about a fly and arrow and so
this is an interview flies doing with it
in this section the two that were
talking about same amount and this is
about am sort of important episode in
the history of the conflict over
squatting in this neighborhood where
squatters disrupted and took over a
community board meeting and I wish some
of the buildings were going to be
transferred to a developer that was like
you know one of my sort of like defining
moments at my time here yeah yeah and I
said I was boring books by trying to
hear because I was sort of like you know
felt like I was the one who sort of like
like had the plant shut down but when it
came to be that moment it's like
everybody was like frozen out that like
you didn't know who was gonna go or
what's gonna happen it was good there's
less cost and it's all and and I wasn't
one to jump out there besides no we're
not going to shut this head-on we're
going to get it or you're not going to
vote we're going to shut this down the
line I people follow but I get singled
out we got beat the out
yeah it was silent moving a picture drop
yeah yeah even though there was 50
people in the road right shocked because
there is so many more people right right
right but I said no election is now
we're so good feat but I
remember Frank for allison's like the
next one in line or something yeah
Franklin and then when they decided damn
it look like what yeah I remember all
hell broke loose just lost the fireflies
holy place man yeah I just knew we're
all locked arms ahead like um that big
shot so these interviews that bring old
friends together to reminisce about
their past in part and into function in
one way and to preserve the community
that shares these memories well
physically there ties a weakening so and
people a lot of people have moved out of
the buildings and over time you know
people travel and they don't all live
together anymore and when they do
they're not actively engaged in a
physical struggle for their homes and so
they don't have to have work together as
much anymore and this community you
while it's rooted in place is
ways dissipating and and so and the
interviews bring them back together and
I want to just play you one second to
last clip of fly interviewing another
person in cart Cabrera and they're
talking search towards the end of this
interview about them how they feel
they're seen by the outside world and
this is actually a pair of custody
shorts you can see the dental floss and
they're not giving anybody warm most
people and doing what we were doing but
they weren't about to move into an
advantage building you know I mean you
know we think about it you know if you
can like an objectified and think about
it it's just a slight candidly is
irrational yeah I guess it's a case is
one of the kindest words i can use but
unless you live in a movie of it in
organic living movement community which
the low recitals party was well it's
insanity you really couldn't you can't i
can't words up yeah i mean i never tried
to explain my life to people who haven't
experienced life in the lower east side
face they think I'm completely not which
you know i guess i added this how i
survived here and they also they just
they just don't get in they don't
understand they think i just moved into
an apartment
I Love New York City to it yeah I love
you spent five years a lot of people I
still your father driving split up
because they you know a lot of times
when I have I get the look of a fully
understand good steal our stuff like I
want their form i watch you were home I
just want to place the lid and so you
can hear how here help both of them
feeling the world and understand them
can come together in this interview and
talk great frankly to each other about
that experience so the last thing I want
to make about at the last point I want
to make about them in real estate off
the street project is that recording the
interviews makes a huge difference the
audio then the audience can spread
through these recordings beyond and
people who are there to physically
listen to it and so in this final clip
weekend here at fly talking about who
she thinks this focus for I think it's
going to be I guess would be a lot of
younger people I think it's going to be
a lot of a lot of like students of
sociology and you know urban planning
and I think the kids are going to like
it and you know anyone who's any kind of
housing activists I think and you know
anyone who's interested in New York
history also you know maybe
via text book so we can see how to
conclude oral history as seen in flash
project marshals this authority and this
power of writing recording and archiving
of capital H history and for activists
memories it legitimate them in a way it
makes squatting into a legitimate
project by writing its history and it
brings these very intimate conversations
between squatters into the public eye
and I'm through the process of recording
unlike the other public history telling
modes in which squatters are speaking
more directly to a public of people who
are not actively engaged in this kind of
activity and these are conversations
between squatters as I said so this
transpose intimacy I think is a real
strength of the process it shows rather
than telling the experience of being
part of the community of squatters and
and so I think many of us who've never
been involved in exciting and compelling
activist movements can remember that it
was that experience of being part of a
community of being engaged in something
dynamic with momentum of having that
kind of intimacy that is often just as
compelling as the as the political goals
and that we can all see the things that
there are reasons and things we want to
change in the world but the thing
actually makes people step up and do
that is often a connection to friends
and so even the intimacy of entering
someone's home is not the same as an
intimacy of listening in on a
conversation between old friends
listening reading the unsub station
gossip is like eavesdropping on the most
private of private conversations in
which people don't even want their names
used and but in these cases or all the
streets weakness and it lacks the
capacity for dialogue and challenge in
the way that these lab conversations do
and because of the level of mediation
the kinds of conversations that have
them between struggling and the 040
activists what worsening tour-goers and
squatters didn't happen and and the
kinds of really intense scrutinizing
detail-oriented how you actually do
community organizing conversations
that's struggling the 040 activists are
having and our interest people who are
already active engaged in these kind of
processes and there's something that
happens it live in a way that is
difficult with the mediation of
recording and so I'm going to end there
and thank you for coming and listening
and open it up for questions